The Maze Runner series turned Dylan
O'Brien into a promising young star
however the final film in the series
stalled his meteoric rise than the top
here's why Dylan O'Brien hasn't been the
same since Maze Runner the death cure
Dylan O'Brien got his start on MTV's
Teen Wolf
he played fan favorite Stiles stilinski
best friend detained Wolfe Scott McCall
and served as a source of comic relief
as the show evolved stars became more
serious and emotional and O'Brien was
able to show skill and horror drama and
romance alongside stiles usually goofy
antics like all good things Teen Wolf
came to an end in 2017 but O'Brien was
already on to bigger and better things
young talented and easy on the eyes
O'Brien was a prime candidate for the
growing demand for heartthrob actors the
star of young adult novel inspired
movies in 2013 he was cast as the lead
in Maze Runner effectively propelling
him into big-screen stardom first
released in 2014 The Maze Runner film
series followed the trend found in
dystopian young adult novels the story
is set in a post-apocalyptic society
where the world is controlled by an
all-powerful organization that the
plucky main character and his band of
unlikely friends must fight against
sound familiar
I believe we have a volunteer both
movies were adrenaline-filled sci-fi
drunks that made back their budget
threefold upon release but what about
the third and final film Maze Runner the
death cure you ask well that's where
things got complicated for Dylan O'Brien
acting can be dangerous especially when
an actor does their own stunts the cast
and crew on the set of Maze Runner the
death cure found that out the hard way
when a stunt involving series lead Dylan
O'Brien went terribly wrong in March
2016 on a set in Vancouver Canada
O'Brien was reportedly struck by a
vehicle on set details a few and
accounts are inconsistent but what we do
know is that filming was halted O'Brien
was taken to the hospital for
observation and treatment having
reportedly suffered from a concussion a
facial fracture and possibly brain
trauma to this day O'Brien is
uncomfortable going into particulars
about the accident and has cut off
reporters digging deep for the nitty
gritty details
it wasn't easy you know it's you know it
was at first filming for the death
killer was scheduled to resume in May
just a few months after O'Brien's
accident unfortunately May came and went
and O'Brien was still recovering fans
and media alike were unsure of the
extent of his injuries as he quietly
healed far away from social media and
paparazzi filming was ultimately delayed
indefinitely without O'Brien there
wasn't much that production was able to
shoot at the same time O'Brien had been
cast as the lead for American assassin
an action thriller based on a Vince
Flynn novel of the same name projects
were starting to pile up and the
pressure was on our Brian in a big way
we don't know a lot about how O'Brien's
injuries affected him physically and our
and lacks it that way he told vulture
there's really been one or two people
who have tried to dig and find out what
happened and I cut it off and I'm
comfortable with where I draw the line
for our Brian the recovery process was
overwhelming and took a lot longer than
the optimistic few weeks that Maze
Runner director wears ball had
previously reported O'Brien took a total
of six months to recover from his
injuries
saying that summer was one of the lowest
points in his life I had lost a lot of
function just in my daily routine I
wasn't even at a point where I felt like
I could handle social situations let
alone showing up and being responsible
for work every day long hours on set
delivering a performance and carrying a
movie it just makes your palms sweat
he told Collider I mean I was still in a
hospital at that point so there's no way
that I was like I was like yeah I'll do
that movie for a brief period of time I
Brian wondered if you would ever act
again telling people the first time I
saw my face I was like that's it however
he was also attached to the film
American assassin which had to start
filming soon otherwise the production
studio would lose the rights to the
story but eventually O'Brien decided to
move forward with the project he
explained to vulture I didn't want to
let it go and I also had this really
interesting deeper connection to this
character over the course of those four
months because of what I was going
through like his character Mitch rap
O'Brien went through intensive training
for two months following the accident
that made him question everything and
assassin director Michael questa
that O'Brien's experiences brought truth
to the character my guess is if you and
I go hand to hand you could probably
figure out inside of 20 seconds whether
or not I have what it takes to make it
through selection process so talking
with cinema blend or Brian explained
that going back to Maze Runner was an
incredibly tough decision he explained I
wasn't sure what was going to happen I
wasn't sure how I felt about it to be
honest for a really long time of course
after finishing American assassin he
felt more confident in his abilities he
said to vulture I knew it was going to
be
hard harder than assassin probably but I
thought if I got through that I can get
through this and I think I'll come out
of the other side being really happy
that I did it and I did a year after his
accident filming resumed on the set of
Maze Runner the death cure this time in
Cape Town South Africa death queue
wrapped up the story of Thomas giving
fans and or Brian closure but what about
that stunt gone wrong in the end or
Brian insisted that the shocks the one
where he was injured be left in the film
in an interview with USA Today her Brian
said my response was actually was like I
need you to leave the same in in a way I
would be more heartbroken than if it
just went to waste Beyond Teen Wolf and
to The Maze Runner O'Brien voiced
bumblebee in the bumblebee Transformers
film plus he's back on set with
productions like YouTube Reds weird city
and upcoming projects lack the education
of Frederick fits all and wants the
problems O'Brien is also back to doing
stunts on the Australian set of monster
problems the film is set to release in
2021 and it's sure to feature the kind
of excellent adrenaline driven
performance we've come to expect from
dylan o'brien back on his feet at last
check out one of my newest videos right
here plus even more Liuba videos about
action stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]